in Los Angeles the big political issue
right now is a blockbuster tape
recording that could force three City
councilors to resign Nuri Martinez has
already stepped down as the president of
the LA City Council and apologize for
making profane and racist statements on
that tape the city council will meet for
the first time since the recording was
made public as Mark Strassman reports
the incident has exposed racial fault
lines in this Multicultural City
Nuri Martinez a rising star in La
politics potentially faces a career in
ruins the first Latina chosen to lead
the Los Angeles city council caught on
tape making racist and defensive
comments during a redistricting meeting
with three Latino Democrats it's not us
it's the white members on this Council
that will [ __ ] you in a heartbeat
that tape obtained by the LA Times
captured Martinez talking to local labor
leader Ron Herrera and fellow council
members Gil cedillo and Kevin De Leon at
one point Martinez talks about the black
child of Mike Bonnet a white council
member in Spanish calling the boy a
little monkey there's nothing you can do
to control him
then she adds describing the boy
allegedly misbehaving at an MLK parade
you have like a little white kid which I
was like
this kid is a beat down like let me let
me take them around the corner and then
I'll bring them back councilman bonnen
and his husband said they are appalled
angry and disgusted no child should ever
be subjected to such racist mean and
dehumanizing comments especially from a
public official Herrera the labor leader
resigned his post overnight within hours
of the recording surfacing Martinez said
she was sorry saying I sincerely
apologize to the people I hurt I ask for
forgiveness from my colleagues and from
the residents of this city
but even after she resigned her powerful
post as council president protesters
outside Martinez's home and at city
council demanded more she should also
resign her elected seat on LA City
Council where Paul the
LA's mayor mayor and the two candidates
running to succeed him now say all three
council members should resign all of
them have apologized but none has shown
any sign of resigning despite mounting
pressure for them to do just that
Tony all right Mark's Mark Strassman for
us in Los Angeles which is unusual mark
thank you very much appreciate that
report